yeah BTS covers the newest issue of The
Hollywood Reporter and they are spilling
all sorts of answers to questions their
fans have for starters the guys have
been on a hiatus for the past couple of
months but it's not because they are
breaking up Suga says quote it's not a
big deal it's literally a vacation and
RM says quote I'm just a young man who
likes to watch stranger things on
Netflix and loves to eat and drink beer
but I turn on CNN and BBC and they're
talking about our vacation it feels like
we're living in a different world it
doesn't feel like fans were ever
actually worried they'd break up though
and in 2017 they made this joke to ET
what do you guys see the group and BTS
in ten years maybe like bulletproof
adults or something BTS also reveals
their early musical influences and if
you're wondering their love for Drake is
still strong yes Frank love Tong the
Raptors the guys also discuss their
hopes of winning a Grammy one day our M
says quote it would be an absolute dream
come true just thinking about it
is thrilling et was with BTS at the 2019
Grammys their first time at the show
they were so excited we never imagined
that we
he would always say it's a dream but you
know still can't believe it on this red
carpet